[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le temps s'est presque arrêtée dans le
nord est des états unis à boston
impossible de circuler son déneiger les
trottoirs
le vent est si fort que les vagues
inondent les rues toute une partie des
états unis est encore paralysé les
trains les avions sont à l'arrêt et des
milliers de foyers restent privés
d'électricité
le spectacle qui est offert aujourd'hui
et qui est offert depuis une semaine est
affligeant mais ce que vous lui demandez
livia religion moi je suis b2g j'ai vu
nicolas cette semaine encore une fois au
parlement européen je ne crois pas qu'il
ait l'intention de partir interrogé par
la presse nicolas bay refuse de dire
publiquement son soutien règlement de
compte quelques minutes plus tard en
coulisses avec une conseillère de la
candidate on t'emmène à madrid et tu
veux te barrer tu n'es rien sans marine
barre toi maintenant plutôt que de
bouffer le plus longtemps possible au
râtelier je ne te demande pas ton avis
ta gueule elle est venue m'avait ctive
et devant les journalistes sur
l'espérance faire mousser et
et évidemment cela comportement que
totalement inacceptable j'ai pas me
justifier à l'égard de cette personne la
cohérence la vision la stratégie font
que je penche pour eric zemmour c'est
certain mais il ya un sujet familiale si
vous voulez savoir ce que je pense de
cette semaine je vous dirais que c'est
une belle semaine exit la candidate et
les fans qui profitent les fans et qui
n'a pas directement les jeux font ils le
font avec les élus il appelle m ils
promettent de l'argent ils promettent
des investitures aux élections
législatives ce sont des méthodes qui
sont des méthodes déloyales certain
nombre de personnes qui s'amusent à être
des agents doubles
tac il a un peu à l'intérieur d'un
mouvement pour essayer de le vider une
partie de sa substance et ça c'est pas
loyal et marine le pen ceux qui veulent
partir partent mais partent maintenant
c'est déjà guillaume pelletier qui est
parti dans l'équipe d'eric zemmour et ya
gilles platret alors gilles platret
c'est le maire de chalon sur saône un
qui est vice-président des les
républicains qui est hanté par zemmour
est ce que vous lui demandez aujourd'hui
de partir est ce que vous faites comme
marine le pen qui dit avoir des gens qui
aujourd'hui font semblant d'être ici
alors qu'en réalité leur coeur ou leur
esprit est ailleurs c'est insupportable
c'est un manque total de dignité de
respect lui c'est lui il fait ce qu'il
veut il fait ses choix et moi je suis
face au peuple de france et 120 g le
peuple de france et le peuple de france
me choisira s'il croit que son rocher
pas grave c'est son problème
[Applaudissements]
je demande solennellement un débat avec
emmanuel macron parce qu'il doit il doit
attendu avant le premier tour bien
évidemment il doit rendre compte de son
bilan qui est calamiteux le débat en
question avait été proposé à marine le
pen qui le refusent que le débat en
question avait été proposé à madame
pécresse avec qui jean luc mélenchon
aimerait beaucoup débattre parce que là
aussi on aura une confrontation claire
des idées dans ce pays ils ont refusé le
débat pour chaque nouvel enfant né dans
une famille de la france rurale nous
mettrons en place une bourse de
naissance de 10000 euros
dès l'été prochain il l'a dit dès l'été
prochain vous rendez compte ça va baiser
dans les campagnes comme des moments
tels que celui ci
vous avez vous regardé de tous les côtés
on est
quelle est la bonne personne plutôt
qu'une prime de 10000 euros pour chaque
enfant né dans un village il offrirait
10000 euros pour toutes vos économies en
seine saint denis où sabine par un
avancement dans tout bourgnon son
programme serait certes ignoble mais au
moins ce serait plus assumée est moins
hypocrite
macron va être réélu dans l'état actuel
des choses les puissances financières
qui sont emparés dans notre pays l'ont
déjà décidé